我们正常人刷信用卡，
我们透支的是将来的幸福，
透支的是将来的经济利益，
也是价值，
对不对，
但是我不能拿这个信用卡来透支我的烦恼，
透支我的以后的担忧，
我感觉这就不划算了啊，
我的话没有什么大问题，
一直觉得龙飞姐是比较智慧的，
所以想参考一下您的意见，
嗯，
是关于个人成长，
还有婚姻这块子的，
因为我是97年生的，
现在的男朋友呢是96年生的，
我俩是在一起了十年，
明年是第10年，
是有进入婚姻的计划，
就相当于是明年想要领证，
但是呢，
我有一些比较嘀咕的点，
有一点想不好的点，
想请教一下龙菲姐，
我们是大学同学，
感情目前也是比较稳定的，
比较嘀咕的点是我们的价值观差别是有一点大的，
这跟我们那个原生家庭有一些关系，
它是内陆城市的，
算是二线城市吧，
他的父母是工薪阶层，
我这边是直辖市，
爸爸妈妈是做生意的，
所以说我们俩很多想法是有一点差别。
另外的一个情况是因为已经涉及到婚姻了嘛，
我爸爸妈妈是很开明的，
比较支持我们的，
但是怕爸爸妈妈的工薪阶层的话，
可能彩礼这块子呀，
或者说是给我的感觉可能没有那么智慧，
可能有点说话不好听了。
我男朋友还是性格相对比较随和，
但是也是比较大男子主义的。
包括我们俩价值观的差别，
在生孩子上呀，
还有包括就婚姻的态度呀，
包括我们婚礼的侧重点呀，
这些问题都会暴露出来一些价值观的大差别。
另外的话，
他的工作是他在跟我爸爸妈妈干，
我们不是一个家族企业嘛，
我自己做了一个个体工商户，
我自己开店有五年的时间是跟他们完全脱开的，
但是我男朋友是跟爸爸妈妈一起经营一个公司的，
差不多是50人左右吧，
由于我在他的城市上大学，
上完大学之后呢，
我们俩异地了一年，
后来他就来我的城市来找我了，
但是这个过程中也是他本来不想来的，
我们还分手，
后来我们又在一起了，
他最后同意来找我，
中间也是经过了很多给他做功课啊，
他最后来找我的时候，
他会觉得很亏欠他的爸爸妈妈，
所以我对于我婚姻的态度，
为什么拖了这么久，
其实他来的时候，
我爸妈妈就希望我们结婚，
但是我拖了这么久，
是我觉得有些很大的隐患，
觉得不是很有安全感，
是这个样子，
我其实以前是比较有自信的，
因为我觉得哪怕我对象是因为经济我们会比较好一点，
跟着我来了，
那我要给他充足的一个经济就可以了，
但是我开店5年，
我感觉我没有存款，
虽然也够自己花，
也没有负债，
但是我确实也没存下钱来，
所以都卡在这里了，
包括我对象为啥我们感情是很稳定的，
就只要不谈到这种大的价值观的问题，
我们两个人互相都是能。
旧一点就是不会说是那种，
就是因为毕竟也10年了嘛，
其他的就想听龙飞姐怎么说了，
你俩现在人家就跟你在一起10年了，
来到你这边工作5年了，
是这样的状态，
不跟着你爸爸这样的状态，
对不对？
你说你没有存款，
那他有没有存款呢？
你爸妈给他开多少钱工资呢？
因为是这样的，
他爸爸妈妈有负债，
所以他的工资给我的花的会少一些，
就基本上都给爸爸妈妈了，
那你爸妈给他一个月开多少钱工资呢？
1万左右，
那你妈对他的工作能力认可吗？
是比较认可的，
他俩人给老师型的那种，
那我感觉人家就已经相当于是上门女婿了，
在你们家贡献价值劳动是吧，
明年的时候，
我作为这样的一个状况，
我必须要给他一个结果，
给我们的感情一个领证，
一个就是圆满的一个往下进一步，
因为我觉得这是对他的一个负责任的一个态度，
但是我自己会有一点没有信心，
想跟你联系挺久的，
挺听别人的想法哈，
那你爸妈跟他相处的怎么样呢？
还不错啊，
我觉得是这样啊，
一个人在工作岗位上，
你爸妈觉得他这个人能力也有，
相处的也不错，
这是很难得，
我觉得还是幸福的话，
对，
这就很好了，
而且他跟你生活在一起的状态的话，
其实相当于你们家招了个上门女婿，
但这话咱不能这么说对，
因为他很他。
这受不了，
那以后也不能说孩子跟理性啊什么的，
但也不起对，
那这种情况下的话，
就明面上虽然不说，
实际上你们家还是占便宜啊，
你们家多了个劳动力呀，
是不是，
包括你爸妈以后生病了，
家里面需要劳动力了是不是，
嗯，
这种事情的话，
首先你要判断一下他的底色是不是善良的人，
我觉得是善良，
我的担心是，
就像你说我不应该担心还没发生的事儿，
但是我一想到将来就实很多事情，
我就会你有点感觉条件，
因为我们都是双方的初恋，
也都没有过别人的那种经历，
我就担心我们过到三四十岁之后，
可能就会有一个大问题的出来，
你比方说如果家里条件不行了，
他可能会找别的女孩子，
如果条件特别行，
他会觉得，
那我也得找别的女孩子，
我自己可能也会有这些问题出现，
所以我就觉得可能就挺焦虑了，
尤其是会潜这个状态，
如果你确信她的底色是善良的，
他不至于说谋财害命，
不至于说吃绝苦，
不至于说我潜伏在你们家，
最终你们家财产都落我手里，
完了之后我再虐待你，
我再伤害你，
其实就是两口子相处的事儿了。
两口子相处的事儿，
你要顾及到人家的感受，
比如说逢年过节，
他想要回到他的老家，
要给他爸妈撑撑面子什么的，
我们也得配合一下是不是？
比如说他的朋友亲戚来这边玩了，
咱们也得面子上给人做到位，
要让他在人前有尊严，
让。
在父母面前有尊严，
要让他在他的亲戚朋友面前有尊严，
我觉得这几点做到了，
其实两口子过日子嘛，
关系嘛，
他都无所谓，
就为网络上有两口子嘛，
他脚丫子上人家脸上了，
人家也不生气，
当然我也很烦那种，
就脚丫子上人家男方脸上了还发出来那种，
老烦这种了我不喜欢啊，
看起么来怎么着都行，
但是在人前给足他面子了，
这男的如果说底色是很善良的人，
应该是比较好相处吧，
跟你爸妈又处的挺好的，
这不挺好吗？
目前状况都还比较好的，
但是一直想着连系您挺久的了，
我是有的时候会突然陷入对自己的没有信心，
我感觉是这样的啊，
姐妹们啊，
就是说信用卡这个概念都都知道对不对？
你信用卡这个概念，
你看我们正常人刷信用卡，
我们透支的是将来的幸福，
透支的是将来的经济利益，
也是价值，
对不对，
但是我不能拿这个信用卡来透支我的烦恼，
透支我的以后的担忧，
我感觉这就不划算了啊，
就这意思，
个人成长这块子，
像我们这种做个体经营的，
会有什么更好的一个前景的，
因为我感觉现在因为我们尝试合作直播呀，
这些反正都在走下坡路，
没有觉得特别好的一个想法吧，
就可以说是你做的是哪筷子呀，
租房烘焙，
包括就是有一些结合烘焙，
主像还是蛋糕这块，
其实我感觉啊，
现在吃蛋糕啊什么的，
主打一定要吃健康，
主打要要吃个放心。
我感觉你那。
应该是在门口放个大屏幕，
门口放个大屏幕，
然后一个高清摄像头，
把制作蛋糕的过程的话来回的播放播放，
我现在正在制作呢，
戴着手套呢，
我都戴着帽子呢，
我可干净了，
我门口就放个大屏幕，
而且我这大屏幕最好是那种别人不容易偷的，
哪怕我歇业了，
关店了，
我这大屏幕还在播放我在这儿做蛋糕的过程呢，
我用的就蒸鸡蛋是吧？
我用的就是蒸奶油，
我用的是什么品牌的这个粉，
来好供你参考，
好来谢拜拜拜拜，
谢谢，
嗯，
记得点赞关注哦。